foreign
exciting video on our Channel today we
have something truly special in store
for you we are going to embark on a
journey into the world of programming
with the help of one of the most
advanced AI models out there charity
that's right in this video we will be
learning python using the power of chat
Jeopardy whether you are a complete
beginner or someone looking to expand
their programming skills python is an
excellent choice it's known for its
Simplicity versatility and a wide range
of applications and with the guidance of
chat Jeopardy you are in for a dynamic
and Interactive Learning Experience like
never before so if you are ready to dive
into the world of Python Programming hit
the Subscribe button give us a thumbs up
and let's get started and before that if
you are one of the aspiring python
enthusiasts or Ai and ml Enthusiast
looking for online training and
graduating from the best universities or
a professional well assists to switch
careers in python or Ai and ml by
learning from the experts then try
giving a shout to Simply learns
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning in collaboration with Purdue
University and IBM the course link is
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered we will
move to the browser and I will show you
how we will open the charge upd or open
AI and use it to Learn Python so this is
the first
hyperlink what you can just search
opening or chat repeating and you can
click on the charge APD hyperlink
so this is the
official website that is openai.com
chatgpt
and you can click here to get started
and you can see that it is also
available on Google Play Store and Apple
Store
so we'll just get started you have to
register if you are a new user or if you
have an account you can just login into
it
you could register with the Google
account also so after registering you
will get to this webpage that is
the chat section so here you will start
the conversation with the chat GPT and
you can find the complete roadmap of how
you can become a python developer or if
you want to be a specific inner field or
you want to become a data scientist you
could just have a roadmap for that so
here first we will ask chargpt what is
python as we are on an embarking Journey
To Learn Python here
so you could see that it has responded
that python is a high level interpreted
programming language known for its
Simplicity readability and versatility
it was created by Guru and rosum and
first released in 1991. so this is all
about Python and you can see that it has
also stated its key features that is
readable syntax and it has stated the
feature also that is python uses
indentation or white space to Define
code blocks so that is
defining the readable syntax then
interpreted language Dynamic typing
which standard Library cross platform
object oriented extensive community and
ecosystem
so this is how chat Jeopardy has stated
python so now what we will do will ask
charjabi to act as an instructor to us
we will ask him
kindly
act as an instructor and give me a broad
map
teach me
python
so like we have mixed two statements
here
you could just use one that is kindly
act as an instructor and teach me python
or you can also ask me that give me a
road map for a python developer and you
could also specify the duration that is
in 6 months or two weeks that's up to
you so you could see that of course I
would be happy to guide you through a
roadmap to Learn Python learning the
code is an exciting journey in Python is
a great language to start with here's a
step-by-step roadmap to help you get
started so getting started what he has
given you is installed python choose a
code editor and then he has stated that
you could learn the basic concepts
variables and data types operators
control structures list apples and
dictionaries functions and modules
intermediate Concepts Advanced Opex web
development and Export projects
collaboration and Version Control
Advanced topics practice and learn
so this is the whole roadmap for a
python developer and now I will ask him
kindly
act as our guide and give us a
complete
plan
to become python developer
and that too in four months
okay you could specify the timeline so
you could see here that absolutely I
would be glad to help you create a
comprehensive plan to become a python
developer in four months
so month one that would be for
foundational Concepts and basic
programming so that would be
introduction to python week one two two
week three two four four B functions and
modules and month 2 in starting we'll do
intermediate Python and object-oriented
programming data structures for the week
one and two week three and four will
move on to object oriented programming
so this is how the child GPT has created
a full guide for you in four months so
you could follow it and ask chatgpt
for resources can you
provide
resources
from where
can I learn
so you could see that it has started
providing resources also
foreign edx
and for Interactive Learning and
practice it has stated lead code
occurring and books also that is python
crash course by Eric maths automate the
boring stuff with python and then the
official documentation that's the most
important thing to learn any language
and the YouTube channels and blogs and
websites so these are all the resources
that chat Deputy has stated you you
could also ask him that can you include
these Resources with the guide
or the course guide or the complete
roadmap so it will do that for you also
and now we'll ask him can you elaborate
the concepts
I should
learn in week
one to two so
what chat jpd does is
it continues the chat so what we have
asked him prior we can just cross
question it and ask him further like
what we can do about it
so you could see that it knows what we
are talking about what we want to
so he has stated that certainly in the
first weeks of your Learning Journey you
will be focusing on building a solid
foundation in Python so you could start
with a weak one only you could just
write week one and then you can see what
it states that is understand what python
is and its role in programming install
python on a computer and set up a code
editor or ID
example Visual Studio code or that could
be Jupiter notebook it's up to your
choice and then write your first program
that is the classic hello world program
then day three and four you could move
on to variables and data types you could
learn them and when you want to learn
the concepts chat chapter will help you
and when you stuck on anything chat GPT
will help you so I will show you how you
can be sure and ask chargpt if you stuck
anywhere so uh we'll ask chair chip D
can explain
the topic variables
and data types
to a beginner
and you can see that it has stated now
you have a online learning sources that
chargeupt has given to you or provided
you and you can also ask chat jpt to
make the concepts understandable for you
so you can see that chatgpt has given
you the answer that is of course let's
break down the concepts of variables and
data types in a beginner friendly way
so variables think of a variable as a
container that holds information it's
like a labeled box in which you can
store different things in programming
variables are used to store and manage
data that your program needs to work
with so this is how shared jpt has
stated the concept variables and data
types for you and I can see like I have
a good hold on python so I can see like
it has stated a very good examples and
it has covered all the information about
variables and data types and there's one
more catch
if you didn't understand this concept by
reading this information you can ask
chatgpt to simplify more for you
so you can just write
just I will copy it
I will ask him can you explain the topic
to a six-year-old like you can
ask the chat AP to explain this topic to
a younger self what are you to a younger
kid
so let's see what it states with
examples
okay now let's see so you could see that
it has started
so of course imagine your special box
called a variable okay you have a box
this box can hold different things like
numbers words and more let's look at
some examples to help you understand
variables think of a variable like a
label jar where you keep things you can
put marbles candies or anything you like
inside the job the jar has a name like
magic jaw when you want to use what's
inside you just say the name of the jar
data types now let's talk about the
different kinds of things you can put
inside the jar there are different types
of things right like marbles candies and
stickers in the same way in programming
we have different types of things we can
put in a variable
so this is how we simplify the concept
for you
so this is how you can learn python
first you can have a roadmap and you can
ask the charity to act as an instructor
or a guide and he will provide you the
whole roadmap and after that you can
break down the roadmap that is these
things we have breakdown that is we have
asked him what concepts we should learn
in week one and two you could also ask
for the weak one and after that you
could just took out day 102 and you can
also ask him where can I found the
resource or
from where I can learn how to download
or set up python in my system and how to
download ID so it will provide resources
to you and you can follow that resources
and if you find any difficulty just
paste that difficulty and give it to the
chat Jeopardy he will resolve for you
and moving on you could ask the concepts
for week three and four and
start with the resources online
resources and if you don't understand
those Concepts you can ask chat jpd to
simplify it for you or you can just like
prefix it not prefix it but suffix it
that you can you state these concepts
for a six-year-old or a beginner
so it will simplify the things for you
and it will show you with examples
and here if we ask him
can you
write a
simple
addition
of numbers
code in Python and explain the code
to me so you can see that charge ft has
responded and it has responded that
absolutely has a simple python code that
adds two numbers together
and this is the code that is number one
variable and it has inputted like it has
input the first number then the second
number and in the sum result they have
added and then they have printed it and
you could see that now let's break down
this code step by step
and it has stated that number this line
asks the user to input a number the
input function takes the user types and
store it in a variable
so this is how you can learn
what the code means what the function
means like the input function what does
its functionality and how you can use it
and then function is used to convert the
input into an integer a whole number
so this is how chat Shifty will help you
understand the code learn the language
and have a command on it so further
going you can ask more Concepts from the
chat GPT that give me some example for
list Tuple and dictionaries and with the
help of examples you could just go with
the
course or the guide it has provided you
and I have an announcement for you guys
that is if you are one of the aspiring
python Enthusiast or en ml enthusiasts
looking for online training and
graduating from the best universities or
professional who elicits to switch
careers in python or Ai and ml by
learning from the experts then dragging
a show to Simply learn skeltic Ai and ml
bootcamp and The Bootcamp link will be
mentioned in the description box below
that will navigate you to The Bootcamp
page and you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered if you like
it you can enroll and if you have any
questions you can just pin down your
contact information on the request more
information section and our course guide
will be happy to assist you on that so
This Is How We Will Learn Python using
chatgpt and you can also ask about the
small projects like if we get back to
the
roadmap Advanced topics and this was our
roadmap that is month three Advanced
topics and practical applications and
here also you can ask chargpt
to break down this course also break
down this guide or the complete roadmap
and it will break down it for you and it
will simplify it for you
if you want complete
road map
or a data scientist
so we'll ask him
provide a
detailed
complete roadmap for data science let's
ask him
so you could see that it has started
stating the whole roadmap and then you
can ask the particular Concepts you have
to learn in the week one or two so it
will break down it for you and then you
can ask the particular concept can you
please guide me through the whole
Concepts and with the help of examples
so it will help you to learn that
concept so this is how this AI powered
power powerful tool chat Jeopardy will
help you on a complete overwhelming
Journey To Learn Python this was all
about our tutorial well there you have
it folks we hope you enjoyed this python
learning adventure with chat jpd as much
as we did remember learning to program
is a journey not a destination and
python is an amazing vehicle to take you
there and this was all for this tutorial
and now let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success in their careers you
need to keep updating your skills the
course material was comprehensive and
the faculty was extremely experienced
The Faculty was able to adjust their
teaching style in order to cater to the
overall skill set of the class in the
rapidly evolving world of technology
it's important to keep up Skilling for
every working professional stay relevant
continue learning
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply load
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here